now talk to you about the mempool
analytics in terms of i think this is
like a very different way to look at
this and i know that you guys think this
is kind of the road to mainstream
adoption so what exactly is this andy
well um the point is what we're trying
to do with belmont we're very strong
believers of the fact that on chain
analytics is going to become an integral
part of a mature crypto economy and in
order to achieve that uh we need to
increase the amount of engagement that
people do with uh with on-chain
analytics and what we have now even even
with wellmath glass and cryptocurrent
all the analytics companies
they look at the data that is of
confirmed transactions in the last block
but before transactions get into a blog
they're first put into a mempool when
they aren't confirmed and by looking at
unconfirmed transactions what you're
essentially doing is you're looking back
on what has happened already but by
analyzing manpower transactions and this
is what we're trying to do with our pro
platform you will be able to see what is
happening right now at the moment
so for example imagine uh where you
would be able to set up an alert of like
okay bring me on my telegram or on my
phone or whatever uh whenever a whale is
sending more than 5000 bitcoins to an
exchange that information will be very
valuable and especially if you not find
that out before the transaction is even
confirmed so as soon as it happens this
is what will bring the most amount of
engagement and the most amount of eyes
on on chain analytics and it is possible
and this is why we believe that manpool
analytics it is the
road to the mainstream adoption of
onshade and apart from that there has to
be enough educational content around it
but uh feature-wise like usability-wise
i think we need as on-chain analytics
companies we need to stop looking at
what has already happened and we need to
start looking at what's happening right
now and okay giving that patch to people
this is absolutely fascinating i want to
make sure that people really understand
this so most on-chain analytics
platforms
especially in their early days but but
still most of them will look at what's
happening on chain what's actually in
the blocks themselves right and so the
way to think about that is uh the block
has been mined there's information in
there and we can understand what has
just occurred but the action already
occurred right and that's through the
process of the block being mined what
you all are talking about here is yes we
should look at that because it tells us
what just occurred but also we should
have mempool analytics that will tell us
what is about to occur so you almost get
a kind of an alert or an understanding
of there is a probability that x is
about to happen and then confirmation of
yes x did just happen once you actually
look at the true uh information within
the block and so when you think about
that there's obviously technical hurdles
to doing the mempool analytics what is
those technical hurdles or how do you
guys think about solving those problems
yeah i can go for it so uh basically
as i mentioned before it's really
important to get even just for uh block
by block data which is uh just analyzing
the historical data for bitcoin it's
really hard to go
when a new transaction comes in you have
to go back and look into the database of
all transactions that ever happened to
you know find out where was the original
purchase price of the bitcoin that is
being sent right now for example and
with memple analytics you just have to
go like a hundred percent on speed and
you have to create like really super uh
you know fast pipelines uh that are able
to you know uh you know have multiple
streams of data coming in and being
analyzed at the same time uh in uh in
the database of the
transactions so i mean speed it's the
architecture
and
yeah i mean it's it's mostly about the
architecture and being able to
get the
get the transactions real quickly from
the
from the network